we've now learned that just before Jared
Kushner pushed his father-in-law Donald
Trump to take a hard stance on Qatar
that he failed to get a 500 million
dollar loan from Qatar Trump will run
the country like a business we heard and
that seems to have happened a very very
corrupt business at that
remember when Donald Trump went hard
against Qatar and it sort of surprised
everyone including Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson Jared Kushner advised
Donald Trump to do that and just before
he gave that advice he tried and failed
to get a 500 million dollar loan from
one of Qatar's richest businessmen you
might have heard of 666 Fifth Avenue
right this is a building that Kushner
bought a while ago and it hasn't been
doing that well it's a quite vacant and
they're having all sorts of problems and
to try to keep the building business
afloat Kushner went to a Qatari
billionaire known as hbj not LBJ but hbj
Hamad bin Abdullah Al Thani and hbj
agreed to invest five hundred million
dollars if Jared Kushner could come up
with the rest of the money that they
needed for this project
long story short Kushner couldn't come
up with the rest of the money so H BJ
said no thanks not interested in the
deal or according to some other source
he said well let's at least put it on
hold for now the bottom line is the 500
million wasn't going to be given to
Jared Kushner's company anytime soon
shortly thereafter six Gulf countries
severed or reduced ties with Qatar under
the supposed pretense that quote they
support terrorism and immediately Donald
Trump comes out aggressively seemingly
out of the blue saying Qatar as a funder
of terrorism at a very high level Rex
Tillerson our Secretary of State was by
all accounts surprised by this position
of Donald Trump's and according to
sources believe that it was Jared
Kushner who was behind the entire thing
and a source that's close to Tillerson
told the American Conservative that the
Secretary of State is convinced that
some of Donald Trump's remarks about
this issue were written by the UAE
ambassador Yousef al atiba a close
friend of none other than Jared Kushner
the Independent News Service went to
Jared Kushner for comment no comment has
been received this is just bad for the
country this is bad for you whoever you
are that's listening assuming you live
in the United States this is using
political capital to fight personal
battles and in some cases it's personal
business battles for Jared Kushner and
none of this is a surprise and this is
why I've been saying Pat that the [ __ ]
the Trump is were bamboozled this was
completely predictable anyone who paid
even the tiniest bit of attention if you
voted for Trump you're responsible for
this and I ask you how is Trump using
the power of the Oval Office to punish
them for turning down business deals for
his son-in-law how is that good for you
this makes it seem as though Jared
Kushner is more powerful and has more
say than Rex Tillerson does and not like
Rex Tillerson is a great guy but he at
least is the Secretary of State he at
least had to go through a Senate
confirmation process sure the whole
reason that Jared Kushner is there is
because he's the son-in-law to the
president and then you add up these
things about deliberately lying three
times on that disclosure form about
contacts with Russians it's just all
very very sketchy and there's no easy
way to get this guy out of power this is
the foreign policy that should be the
purview of the Secretary of State as
depraved and corrupt as the Secretary of
State maybe and that has been hijacked
as a negotiating tool for the profit of
Donald Trump's family it's bad out there